are you a Christian
uh
sort of sort of sort of yeah
what's sort of a question well I've
like a group of people that like would
be pretty religious but we like I
there's just a lot of issues I see in
the church where like feminism has kind
of overtaken the church and yeah I just
feel like there's kind of like a group
of us that don't really have anywhere to
like call home because yeah there's not
really churches that represent us but I
think that's also an excuse that bad
Christians say so I was like maybe I'm
just not a good Christian
what I never understood and and I'm
starting to ask people when I ask are
you a Christian most people would say
well yeah but I don't go to church or no
because of the church is so bad I don't
understand what does the church have to
do with the individual being a Christian
or not because the church is just a
place where you go to Fellowship you
know but it doesn't have anything to do
with the individual I'm just I'm so you
don't understand I'm so opinionated in
the churches they can't handle me they
can't yeah yeah yeah it's like it's like
when they talk about these born-again
virgins I'm like don't accept that men
stop accepting these bad deals why are
you waiting for a used car like they
can't handle me insurance so you would
say that in church yeah I mean not like
in front of everybody but it's like
after church I'm like why is he saying
that oh okay I can't I can't I know I
should no you should speak up yeah and
it's like yeah because it's like why are
you telling and then you have these like
celibate girls in the church where I'm
like good luck selling that used car
with like 20 000 miles yeah you're gonna
tell them wait till I'm there okay a lot
of men go to church to look for a woman
yeah they didn't end up getting the same
thing if they had not gone to church
yeah amazing
um
why do um
why do church members put the the
preacherial passing what it may be on a
pedestal rather than just seeing them as
another person who is teaching the Bible
whatever he's doing why they
automatically put on a pedestal
well it's kind of like
it's kind of like I think of it as like
a coach you know what I mean like if I
have a volleyball coach and then I see
her play volleyball and I'm like oh my
God you're absolute trash it's like you
know I mean I I might say oh well
they're just they're telling you the
right things but it's kind of like well
I don't really want to play for this
team if the coach is trash Oh if I would
describe it really yeah but the coach
have to deal with just saying
Temptations in life that you or anyone
else yeah they're not like
uh protected from those Temptations If
you just think after 20 30 years you'd
have some skill
if you're like 50 60 and you're the path
of the preacher and then it's like you
have you have no skills built up none
they're like they're partying drinking
smoke I mean I'm not there's it's a
stereotype for a reason right right and
so then they're like well what skills
are you teaching here clearly not good
ones if you can't and I'm not saying
like I understand like it's probably
just an excuse to be a bad like you know
to not practice or whatever but that's
just how I see it and so you because of
those things you're not sure if you're a
Christian or like you're halfway there
yeah well I did 12 Years of Catholic
school and so then I did two years of
Bible study in like a Christian church
right so I haven't practiced in probably
like a year and a half two years but I I
know a decent amount about like the
Bible that I have a religious like
Foundation what is it will you say
practice it what is that how do you you
practice that I go to church every
Sunday oh go to church every Lake
in two months I feel like that's not a
good I feel like that's not enough oh
yeah I feel like that's not how
important is it to go to church
um
that's what church some churches will
probably leave you off words but I I
think it's important I just that's why I
feel weird like saying I'm a Christian
if you're not practicing so I feel like
how are you gonna claim something if
you're not going regularly amazing yeah
and so in order to be a Christian yeah
you believe that you should at least go
to church
yeah I mean yeah I think so I haven't
thought about it that in depth but yeah
that's why I'm hesitant to say oh I see
yeah because our bodies are the temple
really our bodies are the church and the
only reason to go to church if you wanna
Fellowship you know learn something
you know a little bit more than what you
know I guess yeah but our body really
wherever we are the church is there you
know what I mean but I know a lot of
people been taught and trained that they
have to go to church if you don't go to
church because I notice that when I go
home to visit the first thing they want
to know what church you go to right and
I just it's nice to go to Cherry Point
it's not a must
yeah I feel like lazy Christians say
that
and I'm one of them so that is not a
must that you go to church yeah I feel
like that's just like a lazy Christian's
thing to say I'm one of them don't get
me wrong
do you uh and so
do you believe that human beings are in
a fallen State the humans call The
Father's Day oh is that where it comes
from yeah oh
interesting
well what do you mean by Fallen state
Fallen away from God oh yes yes I mean I
think if you 200 years ago would be more
aligned with God in terms of morals or
now I would say 200 years ago yeah I
noticed that I don't know if you have
but Christianity is the most hated
religion
it's always an attack more than any
other religion more than Jewish I feel
like they're like Christianity and
Jewish yeah Judaism
um
why do you think you why do you think
Judaism is an attack equal to
Christianity
I mean the Holocaust
the Holocaust oh the Holocaust yeah oh
yeah yeah
but I I do I I know that there are a lot
of people who hate Judaism that's for
sure and they blame the Christians I
mean the Jews for everything but it
seemed as though everybody is going
against Christianity
yeah
oh that's a you don't see it that way
no I mean I do think people are against
Christianity I'm not super like
well-versed like oh I see but um why do
I think that is
I don't know I just think I think people
live horrible lives in miserable misery
loves company it's kind of like it's
kind of like the fat chicks the whales
when they're like when they're like oh
you can eat whatever you want you look
great sis right no she don't get on the
tread bill that's right come on Becky
get on the treadmill
why is it so hard for women to accept
the truth about themselves
why yeah
I think no one tells us the truth yeah
yeah like from a young age you're told
you should be treated like a queen from
a guy yeah why do you deserve that
you're just a regular you're like a five
that's amazing yeah if you're an eight
baby
you're like a five six like why do you
think you deserve princess treatment and
then and you're in your as many of you
know I was just banned on Tick Tock and
we are demonetized on a daily basis on
this platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible